[موسيقى]
حلف النيتو اتفقنا على ان تكون اوكرانيا
عضوا في الحلف والمانيا ترد وبوتين يلوح
بنصر حتمي محاوله اوكرانيه لغزو الاراضي
الروسيه انقلب السحر على الساحر بينما
القوات الروسيه ترد وبقوه المتجر احدث
المنضمين ضد الاجماع الغربي وحلف شمال
الاطلسي واكثر من 650 جنديا اوكرانيا في
عداد الموتى خلال يوم واحد شقيقه
عسكريه والدم يتجمد في عروق الجيران وبعد
ان اظهرت الصين قوتها في معركه جويه
واشنطن تتودد وايران تمد سوريه بالسلاح
لضرب القوات الامريكيه
النيتو يفجرها في وجه روسيا
بعد ان ازداد الضغط على حلف النيتو والضغط
يولد الانفجار لتشتعل الطاولات الاوروبيه
وتقول كلمتها بصوت واحد مرحبا باوكرانيا
في حلف النيتو وذلك على لسان الامين العام
للنيتو انسولتنبرغ مصرحا بان جميع اعضاء
الحلف متفقون على ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا
في النيتو فمتى سيتم الاعلان عن الانضمام
رسميا هذا سولتنبرغ لم يجب ولم يحدد اي
موعد لكنه شدد على ان موسكو لا تملك فيتو
ضد توسع الكتله الدفاعيه مشيرا الى انه
سيسافر الى انقره في المستقبل القريب
للقاء الرئيس التركي لمناقشه انضمام
السويد الى الخلف ونحن نعلم تحذيرات موسكو
وتهديداتها بهذا الخصوص فكيف سيرد الروس
على هذا التحرك من النيتو لتستدرك هنا
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان وكذلك وزير
خارجيه لوكسمبرج جانسيل بورن لقولهما انه
لا يمكن للنيتو مناقشه توسيع صفوفه وبحث
موضوع انضمام اوكرانيا الى صفوفه في خضم
النزاع في هذه الدوله اي انه لا يمكن ضم
اوكرانيا للحلف قبل ان تنتهي الحرب وكان
الغرب ينتظر ولاده مبكره لفتاه عذراء
بينما يواصل
ليعلن انه سيزور انقره في المستقبل القريب
لدفع طلب السويد الانضمام الى النيتو بعد
اعاده انتخاب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لكن مالا هنا سؤال يطرح نفسه ما
الذي استاجد بعد اعاده انتخاب اردوغان حيث
كان الرئيس التركي يرفض تماما لانضمام
السويد للحلف هل هناك امر يدار من تحت
الطاوله وذلك بانتخاب اردوغان مره اخرى
مقابل الموافقه على ضم السويد للحلف سنترك
الاجابه لكم وهنا انتقلت كييف نحو خطوه
اخرى نعم انها الهجوم غير وسيله للدفاع
حيث اعلن الجيش الروسي انه تصدى بسلاحه
الجوي ومدفعيته مما قال عنه محاوله غزو
اوكرانيه لمنطقه حدوديه روسيه شارك فيها
عشرات الجنود والدبابات لتستخدم موسكو
الطائرات لردع الجنود الاوكران بحسب بيان
الجيش الروسي بينما قال حاكم منطقه
خمسه اشخاص اصيبوا في قصف اوكراني خلال
الليل على المنطقه واضاف المسؤول ان القصف
اسفل ايضا عن اضرار لحقت بالعديد من
المنازل والمباني جراء القصف ليعود
ستولتنبرغ مره اخرى متحدثا عن الضربات
التي طالت منشات مدنيه على الاراضي
الروسيه بان من حق اوكرانيا ان تدافع عن
نفسها اما المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
كل ما تحتاجه للدفاع عن نفسها بينما تستعد
لشن الهجوم المضاد هذا الصيف وقال كيربين
واشنطن لا تشجع الهجمات الاوكرانيه في
العمق الروسي لمنع تصاعد الحرب فعن اي
تصاعد يتحدث بينما كانت الولايات المتحده
قد اعلنت عن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده
الى اوكرانيا بقيمه 30 مئه مليون دولار
اليس هذا تصعيدا ايضا يتساءل الروس لياتي
الرد على لسان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هذه المره بقوله انا واثق من ان
النصر سيكون دائما حليفنا ولا يساورني شك
بشان انتصارنا في العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وستكون بلادنا في نهايه المطاف ضمنا
للسلام والامن وبالعوده الى المعارك على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه اعلنت الروسيه ان
خسائر قوات كييف خلال اليوم الماضي شملت
نحو 660 جنديا وطائره سوق خمسه وعشرين
وسبعه عشره طائره مسيره بالاضافه الى عدد
من المدافع والمعدات العسكريه الاخرى
لتدور الاحداث وتعود بنا مجددا نحو النيتو
الذي لم تنتهي حباله في هذا الفيديو حيث
صرح وزير الخارجيه الهنغاري بترس ارتو بان
بلاده تعتبر تدريب الجيش الاوكراني تحت
رايه حلف النيتو امرا غير مقبول معتبرا
انه يجب على الحلف ان يتجنب الصدام
المباشرا مع روسيا فهل يعد هذا التصريح
اعلانا من هنغاريا اي المجر بالانضمام الى
حلف بوتين بعيدا عن النيتو الحلف الذي
اعتبره الرئيس الفرنسي في 2019 انه في
حاله موت سريري ليعود ويقول هذه مره فان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ايقظ الحلف
عبر اسوا صدمه من خلال غزو اوكرانيا وقال
ماغون امام منتدى كلوبسيك في بروتيسلافا
نحتاج اليوم الى مساعده اوكرانيا بكل
الوسائل للقيام بهجوم مضاد فعال ومن صراع
النيتو مع روسيا الى تحضير الحلف لحرب ضد
صربيا الحليفه حيث قال لدى وصوله الى
اوسلو لحضور اجتماع غير رسمي لوزراء
خارجيه دول الحلف ان 700 عسكري من النيتو
توجهوا الى كوسوفو لدعم قوات الحلف هناك
الاحداث والتطورات
اكدت كيميو جونغ شقيقه زعيم كوريا
الشماليه نائبه مدير اداره اللجنه
المركزيه لحزب العمال الحاكم ان بلادها
ستواصل جهودها لاطلاق قمر صناعي وستضعه في
المدار الفضائي قريبا
ذلك بعد اعتراف بيون جانج بفشل اطلاقها
صاروخا فضائيا يحمل قمرا اصطناعيا
لاستطلاع العسكري وسقوطه في البحر بسبب
خلل فني وفق وكاله يوناب حتى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
على ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه بعد حادثه
اعتراض طائره عسكريه امريكيه فوق بحر
الصين الجنوبي واعرب بلنكن عن اسفه ازاء
عدم انعقاد اجتماع على مستوى وزيري الدفاع
بعد رفض بكين وكان الجيش الصيني اعلن ان
الطائره استطلاع امريكيه توغلت في منطقه
تدريب عسكري فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي مضيفا
انه ارسل طائره للتعقب الطائره الامريكيه
ومراقبتها ذكرت صحيفه
[موسيقى]
على القوات الامريكيه وتعمل كذلك مع روسيا
على استراتيجيه اوسعه لطرد الامريكيين من
المنطقه
حلف النيتو الذي ظل طوال فتره الحرب في
اوكرانيا يحذر من مواجهات مباشره مع روسيا
ها هو اليوم يذهب بقدميه نحو تلك المواجهه
برايكم هل تشمر موسكو عن صعيديها لتبدا
الرد على خطوات الحلف الجريئه
[موسيقى]